hello youtube this is my doubles
question answer I'm here to talk about
respect I the race our track record of
for respecting about the human race
itself we don't respect much but our
track record of respecting anything else
that is not human it is pretty more
pretty pathetic and a lot of the
symptoms we see today extensive
deforestation all the species that are
sort of going into extinction and
climate change are symptoms of this
deeper malaise which is basically our
inability to respect the ecosystem that
sustains and fills us take meat it in as
an industry for instance everybody knows
that for every gram of protein that you
derive for your body if you do it
through need the amount of resources
spend is ten times the amount of
resources you would spend if you had if
you switch to a vegetarian diet to get
the same amount of nutrition of protein
the challenges we still continue to not
only the system eating this we are
expanding this because if you look at
what is happening in the emerging world
right now meat-eating as a practice is
increasing causing much huger stress ten
times the amount of resources get
consumed every for every gram of protein
you later through me is it really
required you really need that you don't
you want to think about the ecosystem I
think we have to do something about it
and oh by the way if you start the risk
at the ecosystem the probability is that
we will perhaps get a lot more out of
this and a lot of the problems that we
are confronted with things like climate
change things like of deforestation
things like species extinction perhaps
might be mitigated and perhaps might go
there and we might actually start to
learn to live in harmony thank you very
much look forward to response